President Obama is going to free Chelsea
Manning in four months Chelsea Manning
will be set free because President Obama
has commuted almost all of her remaining
prison sentence you'll remember chelsea
manning the army intelligence analyst
convicted as bradley manning at the time
of a 2010 leak which exposed military
and diplomatic activities around the
world some very disturbing videos of
american military actions in Iraq and
these are leaks that gave WikiLeaks sort
of the initial worldwide notoriety they
were the recipients and the eventual
publishers of the Manning League and
chelsea manning is a transgender woman
in a men's military prison she attempted
suicide twice in the last year and has
been jailed in total for nearly seven
years if you include the pre-trial
detention and of course the initial
years serving her sentence she was
sentenced to 35 years in prison this is
by far the longest punishment we've ever
seen for a leak conviction will be freed
in May of this year four months from now
instead of in 2045 of course a number of
Republicans criticizing this Paul Ryan
calling it outrageous I'm developing a
sense that if Paul Ryan calls something
outrageous it's probably pretty good and
we should be looking into doing more of
it he may just be doing it for political
posturing to disagreeing with Obama and
the last chance that he can let's take a
look for comparison at some other prison
sentences for leaked convictions of
course every one of these situations not
exactly the same but to give you a sense
former CIA officer Jeffrey sterling 3.5
years in prison former CIA director
David Petraeus two years probation and
$100,000 fine former NSA official Thomas
Drake a year probation and 240 hours of
community service couldn't even make it
around 250 hours former State Department
official Steven jin-woo Kim 13 months
and former CIA officer John kiraku 30
months and again Chelsea Manning 35
years
I believe that this is correct Chelsea
Manning exposed crimes brutal war crimes
people are asking well why not Edward
Snowden the Snowden situation is
objectively different in many ways
number one we may correctly assess that
the activities Snowden exposed are sort
of not efficient activities for the
government to be doing bulk surveillance
NSA records of both both record
collection etc but not illegal made
legal by the Patriot Act and other
provisions that were passed number two
Edward Snowden normally presidential
pardons are for people convicted in the
u.s. Snowden is in another country and
he's not been convicted of anything and
and we're talking about a drastically
different scenario and some people
Rachel talk about pre-emptive pardons
but those are very rare i mean we saw
that in the case of nixon right we saw a
pre-emptive pardon we saw it from jimmy
carter absolving people coming back of
people during the Vietnam era absolving
people who violated the military
selective service act through draft
evasion if anybody was holding their
breath for a pre-emptive pardon of
Edward Snowden they were probably going
to run out of breath pretty soon I guess
is the point so they were definitely
going to run out of breath but I feel as
though the distinction between them both
is very difficult but where it becomes
even harder is to measure it because I
would maybe argue that some of the leaks
helped prevent the continuation of the
Iraq war because we had all these
disclosures about the horrible crimes
that the US troops are committing and
then effectively later on they were
pushed out but how do you measure that I
you can't measure objectively but I
think when you look at this on paper Pat
you see the exposing of crimes versus
the exposing of activities which maybe
people didn't know was going on we're
going on but could have if they had been
paying attention for the previous years
we're not really talking about similar
situations I think Edward Snowden
himself even understands the difference
is there because he went on Twitter and
said that if President Obama was to act
on one act of clemency yeah she'd do it
for Chelsea Manning but yeah but he are
already had more ideological support
because everyone was already worried
about cybersecurity a big picture the
Obama administration has been very
aggressive against leakers and chelsea
manning sat in prison long enough for
offenders maybe to think twice in the
future yet chelsea manning personally is
going to be freed and there are
transphobic people saying this is bogus
the only reason she's being let out is
because she played the Jenner I did I
need my gender identity surgery card
blah blah blah whatever you think about
that Chelsea Manning did not deserve a
35-year sentence period I actually
believe it's more likely that Edward
Snowden we'll get a pardon under Donald
Trump given the friendliness with Russia
I don't know if you guys disagree with
me on that I mean they could offer
Edward Snowden up as some sort of
bargaining chip for Trump day and I hope
to get something in return for it yeah
yeah but if they keep doing this is
going to set a dangerous precedent so I
don't know how likely that will be Obama
also granting 63 other pardons and 207
other commutation mostly drug offenders
can Chelsea Manning live safely out
there in the free world or will Chelsea
Manning be a target I believe she would
be a target oh I think she would
definitely be a target from every kind
of nationalist person who believed that
she exposed very very very secret
information that hurt a lot of civilians
and who will be out there to protect
Chelsea Manning one she is living in the
free world something that I guess that's
the next step that will have to contend
with thanks for watching this video
before you watch the next one remember
we're raising money to expand the david
pakman show big league as well as expand
progressive activism go to david
pakman.com slash donate donations of any
size are much appreciated